[Musica]
quanto è meraviglioso essere giovani con
quella innata innaturale voglia di
conquistare e spaccare il mondo e col
pensiero incontrastabile che tutto sia
possibile
e quanto è meraviglioso essere giovani
in Italia
poco
bastano due parole per cambiare risposta
a questa domanda in Italia e non lo dico
io lo dicono i numeri il 50% dei giovani
vive in uno stato di deprivazione lo ha
certificato l'Istat pochi mesi fa e
significa che un giovane su due è
vulnerabile e lontano da una condizione
di benessere fisico sociale e personale
il tasso di occupazione giovanile è
diminuito negli ultimi anni dell'undici
per cento e non solo lavorano in pochi
Ma chi lo fa vive una condizione di
precarietà che le generazioni precedenti
non hanno mai vissuto
il tasso di abbandono scolastico è
arrivato quasi al 12%, E negli ultimi
anni abbiamo perso quasi 100.000 giovani
laureati andate all'estero e Me più
tornati
la quota di neet è arrivata quasi al
20%, significa che i due giovani su 10
non studiano non lavorano e non cercano
Indipendenza
ci sono poi cose che le statistiche non
riportano come un generale approccio di
chiusura verso che oggi è adolescente o
poco più grande si trova lanciato in un
mondo complesso senza esserne mai stato
formato una continua tendenza
semplificare ed etichettare tutto ciò
che arriva da chi ha 10 20 30 anni meno
di noi
Ecco io voglio parlare di Come
accogliere accettare supportare la
meraviglia che c'è in ogni ragazzo di
come far sì che questo torni ad essere
il paese delle opportunità per loro di
come far sì che la domanda iniziale non
cambi risposta semplicemente aggiungendo
due parole Ecco cosa potremmo fare e che
oggi magari facciamo poco
diamo valore al loro tempo
una cosa che diciamo ai ragazzi è che
loro per primi sono portati a credere è
che quando si è giovani sia tutto il
tempo davanti per poter fare qualcosa
sbagliato
perché a volte purtroppo potremmo
renderci conto di colpo che il tempo è
molto meno di quello che pensavamo di
avere
e quindi non possiamo permettere loro di
stagnare di stare fermi ad aspettare
qualcosa Magari con l'obiettivo di
proteggere da un mondo che loro per
primi vorrebbero cambiare
Il tempo va usato bene e il miglior modo
che abbiamo per usarlo con loro e
trasmettere loro l'ambizione Ma
attenzione l'ambizione da sola non si è
mai realizzata non basta essere
ambizioso volere qualcosa perché questa
si realizzi bisogna anche tirarsi su le
maniche e fare e quindi insegnare loro
che l'ambizione del motore e la voglia
di fare sono le ruote potremmo dare loro
la macchina per andare veloci nel loro
futuro
l'ambizione è invece nociva quando
rimane confinata in un idealismo sterile
perché di idealisti ne è pieno il mondo
ma di persone che lo cambiano davvero no
e quindi se oggi nei ragazzi ci sono
valori importanti come il benessere
ambientale la sostenibilità ambientale
la lotta contro ogni tipo di
discriminazione L'errore più grande che
possiamo fare etichettarli
E pensare che queste battaglie siano
vuote prive di significato e far sì che
spesso si siano confinate a volte
addirittura represse e quasi sempre
inascoltate dare valore al loro tempo
significa anche dare meno etichette
e più ascolto
e poi facciamoli scappare dalla
perfezione
da genitori o semplicemente da persone
con qualche anno in più siamo portati a
credere e a insegnare loro che i giovani
devono essere perfetti fin da quando
sono bambini ma la perfezione è un
concetto inarrivabile nulla lo è e loro
non lo saranno mai ma soprattutto non lo
siamo noi perché dovremmo pretendere che
lo diventino loro
e qua lo dico anche i ragazzi scappate
dalla perfezione scappate ma Mirate alla
perfezione in maniera incessante non
accontentatevi mai di un risultato
discreto o di uno stato di appagamento
apparente quando in realtà sapete che
c'è ancora tanto da fare
Se volete rendere questo mondo un posto
migliore per voi non cercate di renderlo
perfetto Mirate alla perfezione ed è in
questa tensione che sarete davvero
agenti del cambiamento
piuttosto che la perfezione invitiamoli
a cercare la felicità Certo La felicità
è un concetto estremamente personale ma
se non sono loro a cercarla non sarà
certo lei a trovare loro E se vogliamo
darla Noi probabilmente li ingabbieremo
nel nostro personale concetto di
felicità
Ma noi vogliamo che loro siano felici o
che loro siano quello che volevamo
essere noi
e poi offriamo loro l'esperienza che
solo chi è più grande ha e anche qua Mi
rivolgo ai ragazzi soprattutto oggi un
sacco di cose potete ripararle da soli
ma l'esperienza no Quella ce l'ha solo
chi in certe sfide c'è già passato
noi ci impegneremo a darvi tutta
l'esperienza che abbiamo imparato nelle
strade percorse finora Ma voi non
commettete lo stesso errore che facciamo
noi non etichettate tutto ciò che arriva
da chi ha qualche anno in più come
vecchio o inutile
diventiamo le persone giuste intorno a
loro
le relazioni umane e sociali sono
arricchenti solo se Onesti sinceri ed è
su questi valori che dobbiamo impostare
il rapporto con i ragazzi perché un
rapporto onesto e sincero con loro
permetterà loro di diventare persone
migliori E così diventeremo persone
migliori anche noi
e voi ragazzi scappate scappate da chi
vi giudica e da chi magari non vuole i
vostri errori e vi colpevolizza per
questi perché fidatevi sbaglierete un
sacco di volte ma
crescerete solo chi davanti a chi lo
capirà e vi accompagnerà l'errore
successivo è questa l'esperienza che
dovete cercare
e quindi noi che siamo un pochino più
grandi Cerchiamo di non metterci sempre
in piedi su un piedistallo magari
Puntando il dito aspettando il loro
primo errore per attaccarli ed
etichettarli di nuovo dobbiamo fare
sempre in modo che i ragazzi siano
circondati da persone che riconoscono il
loro talento e lo facciano esplodere che
diano loro i mezzi le opportunità per
cambiare questo mondo senza metterli
sotto una campana di vetro che permetta
loro di esprimersi ma senza censure
e poi alimentiamo la loro speranza per
il futuro
Mettiamoci nei panni di un ragazzo oggi
guerra a pochi chilometri da casa
una crisi economica che in casa si
respira Ogni giorno una crisi sociale
che estremizza e polarizza rapporto con
coetanei e non continuamente inascoltato
davanti alle richieste di un cambiamento
e numeri che lasciano poco spazio
all'ottimismo è sicuramente un contesto
di difficile lettura per tutti ma
soprattutto per loro è un presente che
lascia poco spazio al futuro ed è qui
che chi come noi ha qualche anno in più
può fare loro un dono meraviglioso
dare speranza ma non la speranza intesa
come una pacca sulla spalla magari
accompagnato da un andrà tutto bene che
abbiamo visto negli ultimi anni Quanta
fortuna ci ha portato la speranza intesa
come lettura di un presente
incomprensibile come certezza che un
futuro migliore ci puoi ci deve essere
Grazie a loro ai giovani alle loro
battaglie e i loro valori la speranza
intesa come mano forte salda in un
momento di così grande turbolenza
cerchiamo quindi di dare meno spazio a
insegnare loro cose che magari possono
tranquillamente imparare da soli e diamo
più spazio e tempo a confronti e
sicurezze come questa
e quindi l'invito che io faccio a chi
non è più giovane perlomeno di età è di
dare l'esempio e di ascoltare che oggi
giovane lo è ancora ma ascoltare
ossessivamente senza giudizio e
pregiudizi e soprattutto senza ridurre
tutto in schemi stereotipi che disegnano
un mondo che piace tanto ai grandi Ma
non è certo quello dei ragazzi
un insegnante
abituata a lavorare con ragazzi per
quasi 30 anni ha dato ormai 20 anni fa
questi consigli a un adolescente che
nulla aveva capito della vita e che poi
ha cercato di metterli in pratica ogni
giorno
quell'adolescente ero io e
quell'insegnante era mia mamma
quell'insegnante poco dopo ci ha
lasciato per sempre
e questa è la formazione che mi ha dato
per il mio futuro e che mi ha insegnato
a trovare la meraviglia in ogni ragazzo
e a credere che con loro è possibile
costruire un mondo migliore per tutti
Grazie
[Applauso]